shelves empty
jobs unfilled
prices rising
who's to blame and do we have the tools
to fix it
tonight the difficult questions facing
the country and the economy
welcome to the great debate
[Applause]
each week we'll dissect the issue
dominating the headlines
this week a country wrestling with its
future and warnings of shortages of food
and fuel
and money to pay for it all
our viewers panel drawn from across the
country and beyond will share their
stories they'll have their say
and they'll put their questions to our
studio panel
joining us this week are
entrepreneur and business owner theopha
fetus
author and activist dr shola moss
shobham emu
al mehmed chairman of migration watch uk
and government adviser on the issue of
migration madeleine sumption
the big question facing them all tonight
does britain work without migration
the government has unveiled its
post-brexit immigration shake-up
promising to end the uk's reliance on
cheap labor from europe
we just don't have enough labour at the
moment to make sure we can protect food
production
this country is a beacon of light and
hope for people around the world
provided they come here legally
it's the biggest mess caused by a
government ever in the life of this
country you've got to find solutions on
your own the government doesn't feel
like it can solve these problems
today's headlines are all about
shortages petrol gas food
but if we could solve those problems
tomorrow there's an even bigger shadow
looming who drives the trucks who works
in the factories and who stacks the
shelves
our biggest challenge could be a
shortage of people
and with that let's go to the wall our
viewers panel
and i want to start
with andreas salvage
what's your view andrea
good evening ladies and gentlemen uh my
question for you guys is the last few
weeks have shown that our immigration
system doesn't actually work is the
government so proud to acknowledge that
i want to put that to our panel a second
andrea but what um what lead you to ask
that question
what's in your own experience
well we're looking at everywhere in uk
especially if you're looking at the
poultry um industries or
um
farmers we know that these sort of
businesses 80 percent of them are
european
and we know they might not be the
brightest ones as the government tends
to uh
label the brightest and the the best but
we all need them are we gonna go hungry
because of that
okay thank you andrea um
i want to go to
another
member in our wall i think ray price has
been
already uh waving to get into the
conversation ray i think people see
britain there somewhere it's a bit like
the decorated and story is london paved
with gold
on i don't think it is
and we're asking and issuing visas for 5
000 truck drivers but probably within
the last 18 months we have told most of
them to go home and now that we stuck we
want them back
but um a lot of those people want to
come and they work i mean it's not
like they want to come and hang about in
the streets do they
well i think if you look at places like
london and statistically the crime rates
have gone up the beggars on the street
um there seems to be a lot of foreign
influence where ethnicity plays a part
um there are a lot of european eastern
europeans coming to britain
with no intention of working whatsoever
i'm more than happy for people to work
in this country i have no problem at all
but contribute to the country
all right um
let's go to northern ireland now
janine moody
what do you make of what um ray has just
said
uh about yeah
britain being a soft touch
totally agree
yeah i mean you only looked at the
australian model and i mean the way they
operate is that
they have targeted immigration for
example
based on the needs of the economy a
brain surgeon could get less points than
a hairdresser
because that's where the need is they
need whatever they i think it needs to
be targeted as opposed to like a quota
system just to please everyone in europe
you know let's just bring everyone in
just so that we're seen to be helping
you know the x number of thousand people
we need a structure and it needs
leadership we need leadership from the
government and we need to be to find out
what our economy needs okay because our
hospitals are already waiting less we
can't take our systems are broken
we will come back to some of that a bit
later but
thank you janine let's go back to
andrea's original questions started our
show recent weeks have shown our
immigration system doesn't work is the
government
too proud to change it theoportis i
think immigration has been a wonderful
thing for the united kingdom if it
wasn't for the fact that my parents came
in 66
low-skilled labor which was required at
the time and they contributed and it's a
second general second generation i was
born in cyprus i suppose i'm first
generation but i'm their offspring i've
contributed i employ people so what are
we going to do are we going to
shut our doors and say you know what
we're going to shut everything down
we're not going to get deliveries to
supermarkets we're not going to have any
nurses we're not going to have any
doctors because we don't want these
foreigners to come here the reality is
it's about we've left break we've left
the eu
so when we left the eu is about one of
the things was controlled immigration so
we have now the ability
the government has the ability to
control immigration so we should have
stopped slowly we must stop talking
about uncontrolled immigration that's
not true but right have controlled
immigration now but right now theo
you've got what 4 000 employees or so in
your businesses
is the immigration policy the that we
have now the right one for your
businesses well we don't know what it is
we just we just say 1970 comedians catch
phrases no more uncontrolled immigration
no more cheap labor we want upskill
labor so someone who picks fruit it
doesn't matter how much you upskilled
them they'll still pick fruit okay
shoulder i see you're nodding at what
theo's been saying uh you're a bit
skeptical
well let me put it this way when he says
the use of comedic um phrases is abs
absolutely right what we are saying in
in this society when it comes to
immigration the biggest problem that i
see is the way we talk about immigration
the question is
about whether the government is too
proud it's not about the government's
pride the government lacks competence
to deal with this the language used
around immigration at the very heart of
it is is rooted in xenophobia and racism
it's very much about them versus us i
mean you listen to some of the comments
coming through like the comments from
ray ray says look he has no problem with
people who want to come and work hard
but you can already see the race
thinking is already associating my you
know immigrants with crime and it's that
kind of language that is problematic
because to your point i totally agree
that immigration has been the backbone
of this country and it's been very good
i might come back and see if we can see
what rey's thought
is about that but i want to come to you
madeleine's assumption um we said that
you're a government adviser but actually
not here to speak to the government over
the migration advisory committee of
which you'll remember you're director of
the uh migration observatory at oxford
university where do you
stand in this debate too soft
or we've got the wrong policy what do
you think
i think the the challenge and the reason
actually immigration is really
controversial is that there isn't this
sort of magical right answer
you know number of people that the
economy needs or is kind of optimal way
of doing immigration policy um actually
the reality is that there's first a huge
amount of uncertainty about what the
impacts of immigration actually are um
and then what you think is a good idea
um is going to depend a lot on what your
objectives are so some people for
example really prioritize having lower
immigration whether you know
sometimes for for social or cultural
reasons
um other people are feel very
comfortable with higher levels of
migration and are happy to reap some
economic benefits from that so i think
it's
you know in this debate it's very easy
for people to say well this is the right
thing to do that's the wrong thing to do
it's actually often the case that it all
kind of just depends on your perspective
and what the objectives are that you
prioritize do you know what the
government's objectives are
the government has said on
immigration policy now that certainly i
don't speak for the government they have
said that their objectives is to have a
high-wage high-skill economy and that
that
so they've said that they will
prioritize
highly skilled migration and have a more
restrictive policy all right let me i'm
going to come back to you guys i want to
come back to the wall who
lead our debate and i'm going to come
back first to andrea who set the cat
amongst the pigeons here andrea you've
been listening to what um
our studio guests have to say um anybody
convince you
uh definitely not the skilled work that
um our prime minister wants to bring in
after all the bottom line is a lot of
our industry depend on these people so
although i do applaud the idea that
people want to be brought in the ones
that are educated we want to doctor with
want engineers we want all that but
who's going to feed us after all they
need to come and bring us the food they
need to come and stop
farmers wasting their uh
their
products
there are so many factories they they
have no staff to man the production
lines so who's gonna be doing that now
they got the concessions they got the
concession for the poultry workers and
they got the concession for the lordy
drivers but all this concession now
they're coming with a little bit of a
german conditions they want employers to
pay for visas they want employers to pay
for troubles from one country to the
other and so on so do they actually want
these concessions to happen or not so
what we're doing for christmas either us
the educated ones or not educated ones
thank you andrea i'm going to um see if
we can get ray back
on the line ray um
you will have heard a direct challenge
uh to you from chola what do you make of
that
um
i think to say that my thoughts are
aiming towards um a racist fear which is
totally wrong i i just think our systems
are wrong and i am more than happy for
people to come into our country and
contribute but the government has to
take control of that and at the moment i
just think it's a horse that's running
away with nobody at the reigns no
control isn't it in 19 uh 2016
i wrote and said
when we leave the eu we're going to have
a skill shortage now if a humble
shopkeeper like me
recognizes
2 000 and 16. where were the government
and let me just carry on with the
government so
2016 we knew we'd have skill shortage
they did nothing about it workshop
politicians you might some people may be
saying now we need immigration in the
short term to feel it fill the jobs that
we need and we need training
in the medium to long term so we can
train people who to fill those roles and
just like any other business if you
haven't got the skill set within your
business you are outsourcing you bring
somebody in until you train your own you
don't shut your business down in the
meantime and say go away we don't we're
not going to have any food we're not
going to have any business because we
don't want these immigrants
actually brexit right decision
execution since 2016 useless i think to
summarize
we've had we've had all the brexit
debate for goodness sake we're out of
the eu what we're talking about
what we're talking about now is the sort
of immigration system that we need
we are not saying no immigration no one
is suggesting that what we are proposing
and a lot of sensible people are
proposing is that we have the levels of
immigration
much lower than the ones that we've had
over the last 20 years which has led to
something like 300 000 people net being
added to our population that's what
causes the problems and that's what
needs to be addressed okay the second
thing if i measure very quickly the
second thing is that the government
really is introducing a system
admissibly that is
supposed to control immigration in
practice what they've done is loosened
it to such an extent that we've almost
got okay free movement extended to the
rest of the world
you cannot have an effective and good
structure for immigration if it's rooted
in a hostile environment again the
language and how we talk about
immigrants is key to how we open up our
borders to who we think should come in
and part of the problem as well
especially with the government's
so-called policy is how they're trying
to attract what they call best talent
what the heck are they talking about the
people who saved our lives last year
during the pandemic would not be
welcomed under this uh would not be
welcomed
in terms of the standards are in place
let me finish let me finish sorry
because if you're only going to be
focused on high skilled and those who
did all the work during the pandemic are
normally seen as low skilled then we
will not have the very people that we
need and that is a problem okay well
there's a i think there's a lot of
reaction on our wall here from our
audience uh i think it's um pretty
evenly divided but whatever it is it's
uh evoking a lot of passions let me go
to gary hagger now um gary actually
is a migrant who went the other way uh
what's your view
oh that's correct i went to germany in
the 90s for about eight years um i
immigrated to australia at the end of
the 80s and while working in germany we
was
mainly english guys working i spoke to a
german bricklayer there who told me
that the 32 guys that were on site
german bricklayers
in three years time 30 of them will be
retired the problem we have is nobody is
trained in noble you got theo there with
4 000 workers i was a site manager for
some of the biggest construction
companies in the uk
not a single one had no price not a
single one was training anyone everyone
out there is just seems to want to bring
in people that are skilled you've got to
train young people young people want a
good job young people want to skip
and you just got to give them the chance
and the opportunity i mean just early
before we started there was a woman on
the front saying we got no labour
someone asked her well how many people
have you trained it how many of you got
training around the corner
this is a matter of interest gary you're
in fuerteventura i think um i am yes
i i i hope sun's shining there but um
why wouldn't you come back
too expensive
um
too cold too wet don't like it don't
like driving on the roads it's just it's
just not nice i come back to see the
kids and that i mean
my wife's there now she's back tomorrow
i'll pick up but no in general i'm here
because i can retire here
cheaper to live and it's fun to have
make it that way thank you gary must let
sheldon react because she's uh she's
bursting there have my birthday
now listen i think the point here is do
we have to train our people and those
over here absolutely it makes no sense
to me if you don't have a class
structured trajectory for people to grow
whichever profession they're in what i
don't want to see
is for those who are coming in the
immigrants are coming in to be at the
brunt of this continued divisive
language around them that to me is
problematic look when when this country
has needed the help of immigrants
whether it was the windrush generation
or those who came for ireland right so
many people came in here and made this
country what it is today i'm sorry we
should not be in 2021 tolerating an
environment that excludes people simply
because they're not i don't like that
all right we're going to dig a bit
further into this uh
we're going to dig a bit further into
this territory
next can our public services survive
without immigrant workers
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
it was from this chamber the carlos
putimon declared independence in october
i want to show other people what
happened
i'm michelle clifford and i'm skye's
europe correspondent
not the aim of the smugglers to actually
get people to uk shores but simply into
british waters
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are real concerns here now about
whether the health system will be able
to case
made by people who dare to challenge
afternoon mr barnier i have no time for
any politics
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the great debate
does britain work without immigration
i want to
have a look at public services and i'm
going back to the wall to talk to jan
adamson jan i think you're in camarden
you've got a question you want to put to
our panel
i have yes thank you for this
um so boris johnson has specified
that doctors and engineers
are desirable migrants because they are
highly skilled
and so my question to the
do we need to consider
uh other
making
other roles and occupations
also high skilled in order to ensure
that we have adequate public services
thank you very much jan that's a very
important question let's come back to
our studio panel
do more roles need to be classified as
high skill to ensure that we have
adequate public services uh madeleine
this is an area you spend a lot of time
thinking about what do you think yes i
mean so the this debate about what's
skilled and what isn't um has become
very heated um partly because i think
people often think the word low skilled
is pejorative it means that someone
doesn't have value or isn't doing useful
work from a really technocratic
perspective um basically the way you
know the office of national statistics
would define skill is basically how long
does it take to trade for this job so
somewhere your doctor would definitely
be classified as as highly skilled
because
you know it takes many years to train
whereas a care worker would not be now
that obviously doesn't you know a lot of
people will look at care work and say
you know that requires a lot of skill um
the difference somewhere and kind of
immigration policy treats these
occupations differently is that it
doesn't take a long time to train to be
a care worker
so i think and then of course
in terms of immigration policy
in general governments you know around
the world not just here tend to favor um
highly skilled migration
that doesn't necessarily mean that there
won't be cases when they want to
facilitate migration into lower paid
jobs it doesn't have such a long
duration of training maybe for other
reasons for kind of social reasons or
because they really value the nature of
the work
i know it can be can it can be confusing
there are many people who would say that
um job i'm doing right now is highly
skilled but actually you don't get any
training for it at all theo
it was interesting earlier on gary
talked about apprenticeships and how key
they are in modern day business and they
are but a few years ago and i thought
that was aware a few years ago the
government brought in this thing called
the apprenticeship levy where all
employers have had to put a certain
amount of funds aside every year for
apprenticeships
slight problem they make it so hard to
use that there's hundreds and hundreds
if not a billion pounds with the
treasury at the moment that employers
like myself can't use on training and
apprenticeships because they've made it
so difficult if they only just ease that
period and it's and it's about periods
it's about not being able to do express
training with things that we need today
if they ease that we could actually help
the skills gap right now the money's
there we don't have money in the pot
indeed many employers said that the
apprenticeship levy was not worth do it
not worth taking because the bureaucracy
involved in using it was too great
alp
what do you think
would we actually get to to better place
if we had a more rational way
of
understanding what skills are needed in
a way that i think madeleine was was
talking about
yeah i think we probably would if we had
a rational way of working that out the
fact is that we haven't and we've left
it entirely to the market the government
has sort of dabbled from time to time
and as theo points out training in this
country has actually fallen through the
floor over the last 10 years or so
that's what we've got to
improve the government i think could do
a lot but employers could also do much
more
as for services do you know that 30
of our doctors are from overseas in the
netherlands
it's five percent
54
of nurses who've applied for nurse
training degrees since 2010
have been rejected if they've applied
from the domestic market so there's a
great deal that we're not doing and the
crux of it
is not training sufficiently ourselves
and i blame that a lot of it on
employers i'm afraid okay i'm going to
come i'm going to come back to you in a
second i'm going to come to i'm going to
come to the wall and ask you a very
straightforward binary question some
people think that this should really be
a matter for businesses to decide and
some people think that the government
ought to be more directed so i'm going
to ask you to put your hands up
those who think that the government
really needs to take charge of this
issue of which skills and training and
that we really need more government
direction
and i think we are seeing
quite a lot of people probably getting
up to more than half who think that this
should be the government's business okay
you can put their hand down just to
think that things that the businesses
that we should leave this to businesses
to lead and that actually they should be
the people who decide who comes in
yeah very few
uh it seems actually scholar that um
our viewers think that this is a job for
government would you trust the
government this government heck no i've
already said that this current
government is the government we got i
know it's the government reminder remind
me again but look the point here is when
it comes to defining
what is skilled low skill or middle
skill the problem here is that the
government is not listening to the
business and the government is not
listening to the people again let me use
the pandemic as an example i'm sorry who
saved literally saved us last year from
the people who the the teachers yeah you
went with that did you make the speech
let me finish you made this one
i want to focus on the question of
whether we want governor government to
leave here or businesses this is why i'm
talking about it because those who show
those who we traditionally see as
low-skilled turned out to be the most
high-skilled when we most need it needed
them so the people who ought to be
deciding it has to be a conversation
between government and civic society and
the government needs to be listening to
what we're saying
what business should
definitely lend their knowledge to the
to the government but the government has
to give guidance that works that makes
sense that is inclusive all of that but
you're not going to get it from this
current government all right let me go
back to the wall i'm going to go to
edward hemings who actually has some
direct experiences in this area edward
what's your view
uh good evening thank you very much for
um speaking i've taken a few notes i've
picked up such something that theo
profits said that actually we've had
four to five years to prepare for brexit
so the fact we've got no lorry drivers
the fact that we've got skill shortage
isn't an excuse i also don't think it's
correct to blame the government
businesses must know what skills gaps
they have and therefore surely it's up
to them
um to train now let's let's look at it
another way i think there's two things
that are missing here and that's
engagement and education we need to
engage our young people and then we need
to educate them we have young people
with whom we haven't engaged for so many
years
businesses are people who actually know
what's going on okay so that is why i
said that the government needs to be
talking to the business and then is to
create the right incentives the right
policies that will enable businesses to
bring them up
or you know on board the skill set
needed within the nation and outside the
nation look bottom line is that
immigration is not a bad thing we've
seen that it can work in this country
and when we say that you know don't
blame the government for everything i'm
sorry but this is the government's
problem because it created this mess
coming up in a moment
do we have to confront an uncomfortable
truth that there are some jobs that
british workers just don't want to do
we'll be talking about that and much
more with the chef and restauranter
jotom ottawa
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
this is the great debate where this week
we're asking
does britain work without immigration
and one area that historically has
depended pretty heavily on immigrant
labor is hospitality of course and i'm
pleased to say that we're joined by um
one of the leading figures in the
hospitality industry the chef and
restaurant
yotum otolengi good evening chef um
i wonder if you could tell us
where your uh where your restaurants are
and where your business is when it comes
to getting not just enough but the right
staff
um so like so many other restaurants and
hospitality businesses across the
country we are struggling to get uh
employees staff uh
throughout from the uh what we call low
skill to the high skilled manager and
head chefs etc there's just across the
board there's a real shortage
of staff and we are seriously struggling
and
i want to say that i represent my own
business but actually for as a matter of
fact i represent you know thousands of
businesses across the country that are
really struggling at the moment to get
to get started in um
pre covered do you have a thought an
idea what proportion of your workforce
would have been people from overseas
um
you know i i i would say that
over 50 percent i i don't have the
figures
with me but yeah there was a very
significant proportion of our staff and
in some kitchens it would be 60 70 80
percent that would have been from
overseas
has that has that changed in the last
two three years at all
yes it has changed
it has changed it hasn't changed
dramatically because many of those non
non-brits are still there
uh but
yes i would say as a percentage of our
employees the number of uh british
people has increased slightly i would i
would have thought what do you think is
the problem for you is it that people
don't want to stay or come to britain
or is it that the
process of hiring has become more
difficult in some way
i think we're with there's two situ
we're innocent we're kind of in a
perfect storm now so post um a pandemic
or in this state of the pandemic that
we're at
many people have left the industry
because of different considerations they
want a better what they could say you
know work life balance which i
understand
and the
hospitality industry has very unsocial
hours you know people work in the
evenings and weekends etc so
that has driven some people out uh away
uh but then there is also the brexit
effect so our pool for recruiting for
recruitment has really diminished from
you know from you know many many
hundreds of millions which is the eu
to to the borders of this country and we
just can't seem to be able to get enough
people through the door to force job
interviews and for the positions we have
to fill
on all levels as i said
are you seeing many
british
candidates coming forward for jobs or is
that still
a problem that hospitality industry
faces that it's just not getting
enough candidates domestically yeah
we're just not getting enough candidates
domestically i mean
um
you know you could argue i guess that
you know um it's something to do with
the way we the way we work you know the
pay pay conditions the the way people
are in this and but
uh but i tend to think that there's just
not enough people not enough candidates
for these jobs in general because as a
rule we can't fill in
we can't fill the low paid positions and
we can't pay for the high paid position
so it's not about skill it's about just
a shortage of people who want to work in
hospitality or restaurants it's only
about what we have to offer i think
there is just not enough people that are
willing in this country that are willing
willing to work in this industry
well thank you so much because we're
going to pick that point up thank you so
much for being with us uh mr ozalenki
and um
we're going to try and solve this
problem because i i want to have more of
those cakes um let me come back to the
wall because i think we have somebody
who wants to pick up exactly that point
that yotum otolengi made
about people not coming forward louise
brown you're in sunderland i think
yes thank you
thinking about my own past experiences
are british nationals too lazy to fill
the gaps left by european workers well
that's a bit of a zinger um before i put
into a panel when you say thinking about
your own experiences what what what do
you mean
um i'm thinking about a bit back when
i've done summer jobs picking fruit and
i'll admit that i was probably one of
the lazy british workers while all the
eastern european workers in particular
worked
so so much harder than myself and my
british colleagues so that's yeah that's
what i'm talking about my specific
example
well
louise brown asked are british nationals
too lazy to fill the gaps left by
european workers before i come to our
studio panel i want to come to come back
to the wall um
louise's question british workers too
lazy to fill the gaps left by european
workers who agrees
with that
statement can i see those who agree with
that statement to your
hands and i'm looking
and just wave them so we can see them
clearly uh yeah we're seeing somewhere
between maybe thirty forty percent okay
you can put your hands down who
disagrees with the idea that british
workers are too lazy to fill those jobs
uh left by european workers
well
it's interesting probably around the
same number maybe it's maybe about 40 50
percent okay let me come back into the
studio alt mehmet
lewis brown basically doesn't think that
we've got a real immigration problem
what we've got is a laziness problem
um i think there's a lot of people that
would be offended at that but that aside
are our work is lazy absolutely not but
if you're getting someone from a poor
country who's used to working
frankly the all the hours that god sends
to uh to work and break their backs
and you have someone from here who's got
commitments who's got payments to make
people from poor countries got
commitments too you know no they haven't
got them to the extent that those who
are families they've got houses
i'm sorry but someone who is say
living working on a little farm in
romania where i've i've
lived and worked is not going to have
the same commitments or needs to someone
all right living in a city in this
country
theo um
let's not mess we use the word lazy but
maybe british workers aren't as
keen uh and as committed to some kind of
work as people from abroad
i don't think that's right i think
you'll never match
employment with vacancies fully you
never have a hundred percent full
employment and no unemployment whatever
we do we're always going to have a
percentage of unemployment and at the
moment
quite rightly as we just heard we're
looking to fill not just
average paid jobs but highly skilled
paid jobs we're talking about six figure
salaries there is still a shortage of
people and so we need to make sure that
we attract the right people to run our
country and our economy and the right
legislation
led by government because there's no
point saying it's up to business if
government puts in legislation all right
that stops you doing something
business can't do anything about it no i
i want to stick with this rather
interesting question which i i don't
think is often discussed publicly about
why there are these vacancies uh i'm
going to come to christian pico who i
guess i think you're in northampton uh
let's bring you in because i think
you've got a slightly different view
about all this kritin pico
yes good evening um
well i worked in venue warehouses and i
did the
less attractive jobs as well
and
what we need
and what is missing from england
people don't have the can-do attitude
that the foreigners have when i go to a
job
and
they tell me
that look you need to do this
okay i do it
technically i break my back for the job
now that would be admirable
in most countries
not in england
well here we go
because the words we're looking for here
are work ethics it has jack all to do
with people here having more commitments
or less commitments i do agree with that
statement those who come here and you
see the high level work ethics is
because they know they need to work hard
to earn and they're trying to earn they
have a purpose and that should actually
be admired that should actually be
appreciated so the fact that there's a
varying degree between the work ethics
of foreigners and um you know british
people that work here that is the
calling and then there's an arrogance
please let me let everything let me
finish there's an arrogance if you vote
or make noise about people stealing your
jobs and then the people go and that you
don't have what it takes to go do the
job i'm sorry shame on you
shame on you okay i would rather have
like to go on with this for quite a long
time but we have to go to a break in a
moment
the rights and wrongs of enticing the
world's best and brightest to britain
[Music]
[Applause]
the government has got an ambitious
target that will reduce our emissions by
two-thirds by 2035
and businesses are a core part of that
so we've taken a look at the biggest
businesses in the uk
and we've disappointingly found that
only 19
have got a plan to reach net zero now
more of them have got a target and
that's welcome that we've got a target
but obviously what's really important is
that you've got a plan to meet that
target and as i say only 19
have made that plan and we can see that
plan so what we're calling for is the
government to to stop the gap and and
not expect that they're going to get
these emissions reductions unless we
have legislation for plans and mandatory
transition plans in the run-up to the
landmark cop conference that we've got
coming up in glasgow in only a few weeks
time we've got businesses falling over
themselves to talk about net zero and as
i say there is a lot of commitments out
there but commitments are one thing a
plan is a very different thing you know
i compare it a bit like to a pizza box
there's calories on a pizza but it
doesn't mean to say you're going to stop
eating it or lose weight a weight
management plan is a very different
proposition and so whilst we do welcome
the companies that have come forward
with net zero commitments there are over
a quarter left in the foot so you
haven't and we'd urge them to come
forward with commitments we're also
saying we need that plan a government
needs to step in the window for
voluntary action has gone we all know
that the science is terrifying we've all
got to step up now and make sure we're
on that trajectory towards net zero with
credible plans alongside those credible
commitments
the government is saying this is their
big issue so if this is their big issue
and they're putting a plan on the table
and they want everybody to to put you
know to come on board and support them
doing that they need to set the criteria
in place and so we need legislation to
make sure there's a level playing field
and actually some of those leading
businesses are saying please do it
because at the moment we're all in this
sort of no-man's land with various
commitments of different um ambition
levels and actually we all want to move
together if we move together you know
not only is that good for the climate
but it could be really good for the uk
there's a lot of business opportunities
for those who go first and go fastest
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
does britain work without immigration
that's what we're discussing on the
great debate
now as we've been talking about uh many
people would like to see only the most
skilled immigrants uh allowed into the
uk to work um carl hider
uh who's in cambridge uh i think you've
got a question on this
yeah hi good evening um
is allowing of only the highly skilled
workers from other countries not morally
wrong
thank you carl
a straightforward question there
the question is is allowing only highly
skilled workers from other countries
morally
wrong
theoprophysis i'm not sure what it means
but morally wrong this is a worldwide
competition for
skills and colleagues and staff and at
the end of the day if we don't make
ourselves attractive we're not going to
be a successful economy now every other
country will be doing exactly the same
attracting high skill rates is very
important to the economy and the united
kingdom as it is to every other country
and the good news about that is you're
bringing everybody up with you because
as you become more competitive you bring
everybody with you
madeline
what do you think i think the the the so
there's the the big debate about brain
drain right you know is it wrong to um
attract people that you know who might
be doing useful things in their country
of origin the ethics of this actually a
little bit complicated because on the
one hand we say okay as a government is
it wrong for us to go out and take
people that another government might
want to have in their country but there
are also individuals whose lives
are being affected by this as well and
so that you also have to ask is it wrong
to prevent someone from coming to this
country
um because those the people that they
would leave behind might not fair as
well so britain for example is a country
of immigration a lot of highly skilled
people um move from uh from the uk to
places like the the us or canada or
australia
um should should british people be
prevented from going to those places um
because uh because you know those of us
who are left behind might have benefited
from having them there so as you can see
it's
it's not clearly ethically you know
right or wrong either way i think sure
there's a point here isn't there because
you know
doctors come from
the development country they train here
and they take their skills back home
yeah absolutely but i think that we need
to flip that question
it can't be morally wrong to to draw or
or to make ourselves attractive to
people that we would like to come in my
issue is using the word highly skilled
because again you're excluding a certain
demographic
from what we think is highly skilled
because those who do low-skill job is
just as important as those who are seen
as mid-skilled or highly skilled and
let's not forget i do not see british
people um especially white british
people are having any problem moving to
spain just for the weather or going to
some other country for education or
employment opportunities but when it
comes to here apparently or we can only
have certain kind of people but that
standard doesn't apply to our people i i
don't think that's right
alp
well
firstly there's masses of immigration
here probably too high as i mentioned
earlier
over the last 20 years on average 300
000 people a year net coming here so
it's not that there's no
no immigration secondly with regard to
overseas skills being brought in it's
where you recruit and i would argue that
where you're looking for skills in
countries like south africa in zimbabwe
in egypt in the philippines in pakistan
i think that those skills that we're
importing here
frankly are more needed in those
countries and it's not a case of people
coming here
but and going back is people coming here
and not returning all right that is
immoral okay so i have issues with that
you may have you may have but i wanted
to take it the issues from our wall and
i am going to talk to michael moe
uh now michael
i think you have a relevant piece of
experience here perhaps you could just
describe your background
okay i'm a former po democracy local
counselor from hong kong we're just
living in exile for three months here in
london
i having a my law master degree i do
have a campaign experience for amnesty
international as a campaigner but i'm
not allowed to wet hair as an asylum
seeker
i'm highly well whether i'm highly
skilled or highly educated it's up to
all the uh commentators to comment by
any definition michael you're pretty
highly skilled but i would say that uh
canada or australia or even singapore
are treating hong kongers like much
better even like
those like us they are skipping like
more like concessions or visa
arrangements
better integration programs and i don't
see this administration this uk
government is doing right to good to
give a better integration program or to
attract like worldwide talents in the
prosperity era
theo
we're not actually doing the job of
getting
highly capable people like michael i
mean it's clear that the government's
immigration policy at the moment is
flying by the seat of their pants and as
treasury spokesman said of another
minister secretary of state over the
weekend they're making it up they're
blagging we're being blagged there is no
policy it's easier to throw out a few
catch phrases they've got to get a grip
and do the job we've elected them to do
okay thank you very much indeed um i'm
going to come back uh because we're in
the last moments of our show to the wall
and i'm going to ask the viewers panel
our original question
does britain work
without immigration those who think that
essentially we can work without
more immigration those who believe that
can britain work without immigration put
your hands up
who think it can't those who think that
actually we can't work without more
immigration put your hands up
well okay well i think what we are
seeing here is people who think this is
an anti-immigration country probably
aren't talking to anybody that we talk
to because that's pretty much a hundred
percent
that is it from us for this evening and
it just remains for me to thank our
panelists here in the studio madeleine
sumption
alpha mehmet
shola moss shogun
and of course
as ever i want to thank
our viewers panel our wall for a
spirited conversation
some things i haven't heard on
television before thank you all very
much indeed and of course thanks to you
at home for watching
keep that debate flowing keep talking
and we'll see you again for next week's
great debate
[Music]
you